a través de su cuenta de twitter el
presidente argentino alberto fernández
felicitó primero al pueblo
estadounidense por el récord de
participación en estas elecciones y
luego al presidente electo joe biden y
finalmente a su compañera de fórmula
kamala harris que se convierte en la
primera mujer en llegar a la
vicepresidencia de eeuu cuanto va a
cambiar ahora la relación entre eeuu y
argentina y generar el consenso es que
no demasiado la política exterior
estadounidense tiende a ser bastante
estable y argentina no es un punto que
sobresale especialmente en el radar de
la política exterior del país
norteamericano para argentina si es
importante el rol de eeuu en el fondo
monetario internacional donde tiene
poder de veto argentina está
renegociando su deuda de 44 mil millones
de dólares con el organismo pero ese es
un proceso que ya está iniciado y
encaminado y nada indica que vaya a
cambiar el resultado por quien ocupe la
casa blanca en eeuu